la pena de 25 años de prisión impuesta
al opositor ruandés Paul rusabalina ha
sido conmutada por decreto presidencial
el gobierno sostiene que a ojos de la
ley sigue siendo culpable de terrorismo
[Música]
no hay duda de que se cometieron delitos
no hay duda de que se respetó el
procedimiento adecuado y no hay duda de
que el señor russezabalina fue condenado
porque se lo merecía
sobre este punto no hay duda
inspiró a la película nominada al Oscar
hotel Ruanda basada en el rescate de más
de 1000 personas durante el genocidio de
los tutsis del país en 1994 su
Liberación se produce tras meses de
negociaciones entre Estados Unidos donde
él residía y Ruanda la detención de
Rusia gallina en 2020 fue criticada por
Estados Unidos y también por Bélgica
país que él es ciudadano así como por
varias ong
la decisión de secuestrar de meterlo en
un jet privado para llevarlo por la
fuerza de vuelta a Ruanda demuestra que
ni siquiera ellos creen en la
legitimidad de las pruebas en su contra
en 2021
crítico del presidente ruandés polkagame
fue condenado por mantener vínculos con
el frente de liberación nacional que
kigali considera grupo terrorista rusa
ballena que vivía en el exilio desde
1996 ha admitido su pertenencia a un
partido político pero niega cualquier
vinculación con atentados terroristas
del fnn